now that I got to play a little total
war Troy I'm joined by one of the senior
designers mil show Vasilev to talk about
how they're combining the mythology of
ancient Troy with total war mechanics so
that the biggest aspect is I think for
Troy is how does the mythology tie into
the game yeah so we were exploring this
period which is so back in time the end
of the Bronze Age and there is a very
very little record of what exactly how
exactly things were at the time we do
have artifacts and archaeological finds
because fortunately Bronze Age is pretty
well in the ground and we can still dig
those stuff up and make some educated
guesses about how people probably lived
were behaved or how they constructed
cities and so on but most of it all
remains a mystery to us so we were
thinking really hard about how to
approach this period because this is the
first time that a total war game goes so
back in time all the way to the Bronze
Age and we decided that Homer's Iliad
could be a perfect inspiration for us
because even though it's probably a work
of fiction it has recently been
discovered that it is based on true
events and even though what Homer writes
about is probably not I didn't probably
occur exactly as he said it a lot of the
characters the kings the locations they
probably did exist so you send them
centaurs and is this - [ __ ] in the
game how how much of the the myth of the
era are you tapping into when it comes
to what units you can create we are more
or less scratching the surfaces of the
myths we are still keeping the game
quite historical and all the mythic
units are things that are optional
players usually need to go out of their
way conquer certain regions or gain the
favor of certain gods in to be able to
recruit those types of units but the
whole aesthetic
the game is a sort of an exploration of
the myths because even when you look at
the campaign map you can see that the
unexplored parts of the campaign map are
shrouded by this we called the Shroud of
war which obscures vision on the map and
it's decorated with all those mythical
beings on it those mythical cities and
so on but once you get to explore the
lands the shroud burns away and reviews
what is the truth behind those myths
that were there so without giving too
much away then is there going to be more
aspects than the people are going to
recognize from what they learn in
history that you're going to implement
in the game beyond you know monitors and
because we do have we'd have more than
that in fact we divide them into several
different types like the Minotaur is one
type which is a single entity unique
kind of methodological unit because you
can't have two minotaurs in your army is
a special type of unit which you will
need to earn you need to earn the favor
of Zeus I believe in order to be able to
access him in campaign and he is a
strong unit but he is one and unique
where we have other mythic units like
the Centaur who are a whole bunch of
like a whole tribe and different units
because I'm not sure if you played the
demo which you gave in to them when you
had only centaurs with spears and
shields but in the game they're centaurs
with javelins or scouting centers or
centaurs with bows and this goes on for
the other medic units attack as well we
have other single entity unique mythic
units like the Cyclops for example or
other mythic units that can be a whole
group like the Giants and what we also
have on the campaign map the return of
agents for sagger game and we do also
have some
the mythic agents which we call them
which are only represented on the
campaign map and don't really fight in
the battles and then we have the sole
you divine real system which represents
the way people interacted with the gods
at the time because people were really
really religious in the Bronze Age
they're believing that gods were walking
among them and were all over the world
everywhere in their lives and so we have
this system in which the player can do
can try to appease the gods in different
ways and gain the favor of different
gods thus gaining different Bulls in
either campaign or battle it feels like
there's an extra layer of strategy now
that you've kind of revamped the
resource system as well instead of just
purely if you have enough gold you can
buy this unit can you how is that going
to play into the the grand campaign as
well as in in battles well the new
multiple resource economy system that we
have in Troy has a huge huge impact in
every single aspect of the game because
this is something that hasn't been done
in a total war game before but we
believe that it really opens up the game
giving different tactical advantages
mostly on the campaign map but also in
battles because of the types of troops
you can recruit because now instead of
just having one resource in gold for
example like you have in previous game
you have five different trade resources
which you have to actively gather or try
to trade with other factions so that you
can get them because this only came
natural with the Bronze Age because we
knew that in the Bronze Age they were
not really using a single currency for
exchanges and so on they were usually
doing partisan goods like if you have
access to a lot of food you might give
that food to a neighboring faction so
that you get some food from them for
example and so even at the start of the
campaign different factions have access
to different resource so your faction
might be very rich in a place where
there's access to a lot of bronze and a
lot of
old but you probably don't have access
to fruit and you need to figure out ways
in which you can acquire that fruit you
can try and barter for it and give your
precious resources of gold and bronze to
get that food or you can try and conquer
neighboring factions that have access to
some food and try it in the offensive
way this is all up to the player of
course and when it comes to units and so
on of course different those different
resources are used for different types
of stuff so you need a lot of food to be
able to sustain large armies and to be
able to recruit new units and so on but
if you want to really get elite units
really powerful units you will need to
have access to bronze or gold but
without the food you will still have a
very small army which even if it's
filled with elite units might not be
able to withstand attacks coming out
from different directions and so on so
you need to decide what you want to aim
for and the wood and the stone you will
need for buildings to improve on your
settlements to make sure that your
economy is growing and can support even
larger armies and make you a stronger
and more influential part on the
campaign you talked like about you know
what what you need to create your your
armies but I feel like in in Troy the
armies that the Army's going to look a
lot different than in previous talk wars
because now infantry are so much more
important maybe because of the
technological restrictions and resource
restrictions at the time you've had to
revamp
infantry yes we knew when we were making
a game about the Bronze Age that this
was going to be one of the biggest
challenges that we were going to face
because there is a reason why the Total
War series haven't gone that back in
time until now and yes we knew that this
period is dominated by infantry combat
because that is how they did war at the
time and so we knew that we had to make
sure that infantry against infantry
still feels interesting to play and we
did a lot of things to try and improve
on that there there's not something that
is revolutionary in the game but what we
did is we've taken the weight classes
that we usually had four units and made
them much more distinct giving the
ethan's infantry units different types
of classes and different purposes inside
the battle like the heavy infantry is
that are the toughest units which can go
and fight hand-to-hand with others and
are really to take yet on but if they
get tired really quickly if they have to
move from one location to another to
defend different places they will become
exhausted and becoming exhausted now has
larger impacts on on units on the
battlefield so they will lose more of
their defence or a fan skill and will
become easier targets for enemies
whereas light infantry even though they
can't really stand toe-to-toe with the
heavier counterpart they can outmaneuver
them outflank them they don't get tired
as quickly they can move fast throughout
the battlefield and ignore some of the
new terrain types that we've put on like
the mud which will slow down heavier
units a lot more and have a huge impact
on them whereas if you have almost no
impact on light infantry because they
can just walk through it pretty fast and
use for example the toe grass dream for
change they can hide and wait for an
ambush and try to do some more attacked
something more tactical it feels like a
lot of what you're doing is it feels
like almost like a testbed for total
wars to come there's a lot of tweaks
that you're making and experimenting
with new things like the resource system
and reworking infantry do you do you
feel like this that you're kind of at
the cutting edge of what total wars
going to be now like mixing mythology
with history and experiments new things
well since this is a saga title and saga
titles are a bit smaller in scope
usually focused on a single conflict in
time rather than a whole Europe we
believe that saga titles are the perfect
opportunity for us to be
trying new things because we are yet to
see how all those new features will be
received by the players and how they
will like them or not like them and
that's why we think that this kind of
title is the perfect fit for something
like that and it all just made perfect
sense
in hindsight when you look at it when
you look at the error that we are trying
to cover with all the mythology behind
it and it just makes sense for those
things to be there so do you think that
I suppose depending on how well Troy is
received do you think it might give you
the opportunity to revisit cultures and
eras that have already been explored in
total war but not to the level of
combining mythology and inspirations
it's absolutely possible of course I
mean we always try to learn from the
previous titles and see what people
enjoy or don't enjoy like for example we
knew that a lot of the new diplomacy
system that we introduced in total were
three kingdoms was very well received by
a lot of players so we decided that we
should incorporate that diplomacy system
into Troy as well so all those part of
agreements that you can do the quick
deal to make it work buttons and so on
this is all in the total world Troy as
well and I imagine that this can keep on
going in the future where if something
proves to be a really great concept like
the multiple resource economy for
example or the mythological layer of it
all we can go on and keep doing that in
other total work titles so I think the
the main thing that people think of when
you talk about Troy other than Brad Pitt
in in bronze armor and are you gonna
implement a big horse full of men whoa
both yes and not exactly in the way that
you probably imagined it so of course
this is the Trojan War and
we had to have a Trojan horse of some
sorts so we were thinking a lot about
how how to represent this myth about the
Trojan horse being the way that this is
tricked the Trojans into sneaking up
some units inside the city and so on so
we had several different ideas about it
and in the end we just decided that
we're going to incorporate all of them
so there's different ways in which the
Trojan horse might appear to you in game
one of them is this traditional thing
that with the gift of the wooden horse
with soldiers inside hiding inside of it
but it's again a bit more realistically
than some speak because after doing some
research we saw that the fennekin's
ships usually have horse heads on top of
them and if you in campaign you are
playing with Odysseus or if you manage
to get Odysseus on your side or
Confederate him because that is possible
to happen him he might come come up with
a plan where you that take one of those
ships you fill it up with gold and goods
and offerings to the gods and give it to
the Trojans for them to take inside your
city but people are actually hiding
inside the ship and so the players will
be able if they get to experience that
scenario because as I said you'd need to
have access to this is in one way or
another in order to do that exact thing
players can decide which units they
wanna sneak into the city and once
the trap is sprung they will get to play
a different battle map of Troy where
they will start with some of their units
already inside of the city the gates
opened and the rest of their army
outside the battle would be fought at
night and so it will have a much much
more different feel to it than if you
just decide to salt
Troy's head on
and this is just one of the
representations of the Trojan horse
we've had because from example another
probably not so popular theory was that
after excavating to Troy and looking at
the walls archaeology
archaeologists found that the walls of
Troy were a bit like wave-like structure
to them and they were really curious
about why that would have been and later
it was discovered that it was most
probably due to earthquake because this
this region is very seismic and the
period itself was also very seismic so
it is quite possible that it was
actually an earthquake that brought down
the walls of Troy because Poseidon whose
animal associated with him because
Greeks used to associate a lot of
animals with their gods always is the
horse Poseidon is also the god of
earthquakes also the god of seas and
oceans but in but the god of earthquakes
as well so it might be Poseidon's doing
that he caused an earthquake that would
shatter the walls of Troy does being
interpreted as the Trojan horse so if
you get to experience that scenario and
that scenario can be experienced with
all the factions because it's an
earthquake and you take advantage of it
and attack the Troy right after their
this earthquake again the battle map
will be vastly different with most of
the walls of Troy well at least the
outer walls of it crumbled and turned to
dust and defensive towers would be
broken so you have much easier time
assaulting the city so this is another
representation we have of the Trojan
horse right well thank you so much for
coming on and sharing your wisdom all
things Troy and I suppose as soon as you
guys let me play I'll definitely be
playing again and I'll share it with
everyone at home and thank you so much
for coming on thanks for having me
[Music]